thank you all for joining us at this special
CNN keep watching screening event.
I'm dr Tara Narula CNN medical correspondent
and I'm so thrilled to be joined by Dr Fabi
Hirsch Cruise Ceo and director of clinical
services at Friends of Aphasia. What an incredible
film and story Dr Hirsch. So let's jump right
in. I want to begin with having you describe
for us the very first time that you met then
Representative Gabby Giffords. Yeah. So I
met her for the first time in her home. She
and her husband Mark Kelly had invited me
over really to interview for a speech pathology
position to work with Gabby. She had just
returned from Houston where she was receiving
therapy services there to come back to Tucson.
She was very excited to come back and I was
invited to meet her and see if it would be
a good fit. And so I went to her home and
I remember I was seated at the kitchen table
and she came in, she was singing, she walked
right over, sat across from me and just reached
out and took my hand and just just looked
at me with this beautiful beaming smile and
I knew right away that I definitely wanted
to be part of her rehabilitation rehabilitation
process. And um I felt like it was going to
be a good match and it really has been a good
fit. It's been a really special team for 13
years. Well of course we about about 10 years.
So it's been 10 years that the two of you
have been working so closely together and
of course we We all remember the horrific
mass shooting that injured representative
Giffords and nearly took her life. Six people
were tragically killed that day. 13 people
were wounded. For those in our viewing audience.
Can you give us a brief description of the
kinds of brain injuries that she sustained
and specifically the kind of injury that resulted
in her needing your care? So the gunshot wound
through Gabby's brain really hit just those
speech and language areas that she needs for
communication. So much of the rest of her
brain was spared and that's why she really
relies on speech and language services to
help with her rehabilitation. I rarely see
people following a gunshot wound to the head
because most people don't survive. So Gabby
is incredibly remarkable in her story, in
her recovery because she is you have such
a fighter and continues to improve. And so
most of the people you treat if it's not from
brain injuries that are traumatic from a gunshot,
for example, what are the kinds of causes
of injuries that can result in speech difficulties
or language issues? Yeah, so for aphasia,
specifically the most common cause is stroke.
So about 80% of people who are living with
aphasia have it as a result of a stroke, but
other causes can also result in aphasia. So
brain tumor or an infection or brain degeneration,
anything that can impact the language areas
of the brain can result in aphasia and so
many people don't know what aphasia is. Can
you tell us? How do you define Aphasia? Yes.
So aphasia is the loss of the ability or at
least part of the ability to use words to
communicate. And often we think of communication
just from the perspective of speech or speaking.
And certainly people who have Aphasia have
difficulty with speaking. We also need to
take information in when we're communicating
with others, so comprehending what others
are saying and written communications. So
we write to express ourselves. We read to
take information in all of those areas. Speaking,
understanding reading and writing can all
be impacted by Aphasia. A really important
thing though to keep in mind is that Aphasia
impacts language and communication. It does
not impact intelligence or cognition. Thinking
skills strong as ever. It really impacts the
ability to use language to communicate. Which
I think is almost doubly frustrating because
people who have Aphasia know exactly what
they want to say. But it's such a struggle
to get those words out. And your group actually
has a special bracelet that you wear. What
are the words inside that bracelet. So I would
be people would not be happy if I wasn't wearing
my bracelet. So we do have our friends, we
have our friends of Aphasia bracelet, but
with so few people knowing what Aphasia is.
We also have the definition on the inside.
So it says aphasia loss of words not intelligence.
Such an important point to make and thank
you for explaining that I want to go back
to Gabby. Are there particular challenges?
Uh in her instance for example to recovering
from aphasia, what does the trajectory of
recovery look like? How long can it take?
What is the prognosis? Yeah, so everyone is
very different in how they are living with
Aphasia, just the severity or if it's reading
is more difficult or speaking. And for Gabby
specifically she does have difficulty in each
of the language areas I mentioned. So speaking
is certainly difficult for her to come towards
easily to build those words into sentences.
She does have some real strengths like remembering
people's names, which can often be really
difficult for all of us. She is masterful
at remembering people's names. I rely on her
for that. Um but also she has some struggles
taking information in sometimes. So it's helpful
um you know to to be able to really see people
when they're interacting with her is is very
helpful. Um and reading and writing are tricky
as well, so she works really hard in all of
those areas because they're so important to
her. But she's also very wise in using strategies
to support. So for instance when she wants
to read something from the paper, she also
listens to it on her ipad. So she gets the
information in both by listening and by reading
and she's just very good at using these techniques
to help ensure that she's getting the full
message as far as oh, I was just gonna say
as far as the trajectory of recovery, she
continues to improve. And I do worry that
in the medical community and just in the communities
in general, there is this notion that there's
a plateau that somehow after six months or
12 months or 18 months, that there will be
no more progress and that certainly has not
been my experience with Gabby with all of
the people I work with at our Aphasia Center,
people continue to improve and there may be
areas maybe writing is kind of on a not showing
those kinds of gains for a bit because our
brains need time to consolidate information.
You know, you learn a new skill, you need
time for your brain to really anchor that
skill and then it can start growing again.
So unfortunately in our health care system,
we often look at those times where it feels
like a plateau, but it's really just a time
where our brain is consolidating information
and getting ready to work on showing some
gains again. So it's, it's important that
people realize and Gabby is such a remarkable
example of that, that recovery doesn't stop
with good support. It can continue to go on
and on and on. And we certainly see that.
And the two of you co founded a nonprofit
friends of Aphasia why? Uh and what are some
of the other misconceptions around aphasia,
You mentioned the concern with intelligence
and explained that are there any other misconceptions
that individuals with Aphasia, that people
perceive them differently? Because so few
people know what aphasia is when they interact
with someone who has aphasia, they often can't
quite make sense of of what is causing the
communication difficulty. And just as an example,
so most of our members will carry a card that
says they have aphasia so that if they are
in a situation, for example, we've had members
who have gotten into fender benders and when
the other driver or the police arrive to be
able to show that they have aphasia and that's
why they're struggling to communicate will
dispel. What is often a first thought is that
the person has been drinking or the person
has been doing drugs and that's why they can't
talk properly. So that's always something
that we worry is that people will think something
else is causing somebody not to be able to
get to their words. And so really being able
to let folks know right away. So there isn't
that misconception, that's certainly something
that we, that we worry about. And also we
worry that people will think because people
can't communicate that they don't have those
intact thinking skills, that their intelligence
isn't intact. And it it most certainly is,
it most certainly is. And we see it despite
the communication difficulties every day at
the ASia Center? obviously it's so important
in an individual's recovery to work one on
one with a speech therapist, but talk to me
a little bit about what the benefit is of
being in a group with other individuals who
have Aphasia. What does that do in terms of
support and helping and recovery? Yeah, I
think for me our Aphasia groups are the most
valuable resource I can offer for people living
with Aphasia. Our Aphasia groups are really
designed to address two goals. So we certainly
want to work on improving communication skills.
So we have groups that work on word finding,
reading, writing, but a really big second
piece is the camaraderie and support and friendship
that we foster within our community at the
Aphasia Center and just meeting other people
who are struggling with the same difficulties
can be a huge benefit in the recovery process.
And we have folks there certainly folks who
come to our Aphasia Center who really are
focused on improving their skills and then
there are some who come because it's so fun
and they have such good friends there and
we really have a beautiful community where
we're all very supportive of one another,
get to know each other and get to share our
experiences without worrying that people won't
understand us. We're very supportive. Um so
I I love our Aphasia groups and the support
that we can see the group members provide
to each other. It's just wonderful. I definitely
saw that when I visited, it was apparent and
I know all of you hang out outside of group
two on bike rides and hikes and and other
activities. So it's great to see that that
camaraderie um I want to ask you about the
film and your involvement, what was your initial
reaction to the idea of a film and to the
idea of having therapeutic sessions be filmed
or to kind of reveal that behind the curtain.
Look at what that process was like. We always
think about that very intimate patient doctor
therapist relationship and this was sort of
pulling the curtain back a little bit. Yeah,
they, most of the filming was done during
the pandemic. So Gabby and I spent a lot of
time together on zoom um doing our therapy
sessions, we we were probably able to spend
more time than usual together. Well, virtually
because she didn't have her very busy travel
schedule at that time. Um so we spent a lot
of time together and we recorded all of the
sessions for gosh, many, many months and I
think initially I was a little concerned because
you know, I'm just sitting in front of a zoom
session with someone, I don't really worry
about anyone else seeing it. It is like you
said that sort of intimate um dynamic just
between you and your patient. Um but then
if you ever do start thinking oh a lot of
other people could be seeing this. But I think
that passed very quickly. And part of that
is just Gabby's nature. You get drawn into
the session and you're just enjoying your
time with her. And I don't really think about
the fact that anybody else might be watching
this I think later I was like oh gosh did
I brush my hair before every session? But
yeah it was I love how they captured really
are are dynamic and especially Gabby's just
compassion and her concern for everybody else.
You know you really feel like oh as a clinician
I should be the one supporting her. And in
the film the very first scene that we're both
in she is showing just what a compassionate
person she is and makes me smile every time
to see that section. Did you think it was
important as well to show some of her struggles
during therapy To give insight into just how
hard and frustrating it can be? I think so
and I give the directors Betsy and julie a
lot of credit for not just sugarcoating things
and really demonstrating the struggles that
she has and I think it is important to for
others to see that because I feel like people
often see a speech that she gives or you know
certainly at the Democratic National Convention
when she gave her speech they think oh she
has recovered she is fluent and I've heard
people say oh well she just reads it. It is
certainly not that easy by any means. We spent
almost a year working on the D. N. C. Speech
And I think it's important for people to see
that for her to give these beautifully fluent
speeches. They start in a place that is really
difficult with and targeting each word and
then each line and then line after line and
just practice and practice and practice. So
both for just people in general to see the
type of determination and dedication that
goes into those speeches. But then for people
who are living with Aphasia or any disability
that the determination can help really get
folks far. And I think that will inspire people
to really work hard and do their best. And
I know Gabby is hopeful that that's how other
people will leave the film as well. Just feeling
inspired to do their best. And what feedback
have you gotten so far from people who have
seen the film? Everybody has said they love
it but I'm not sure they would say anything
else to me. I have to say. So I've seen it
several times and when I leave each time I
watch it after the words I always feel so
uplifted. But then I'm always surprised when
I watch it the next time because the first
parts of the film are so difficult like they
you know Mark you know so lovely that Mark
and Gabby both decided to share early footage
from when she was in the hospital and things
that are really hard, I think, to see even
for me. And then as the film proceeds. And
again, I think this is where the directors
were masterful in just taking us from a place
of real tragedy to this, this wonderful life
story. It's it's really beautiful. Do you
know how Gabby Giffords and Mark Kelly feel
about the film? I think they're really happy
with it. I know I've heard Mark say that he
was told never to let anyone make a documentary
about them. Um but they're I think they're
very pleased with how it all turned out and
um it's really just to be able to highlight
Gabby's incredible determination and strength
and to be able to show their very unique relationship,
I think also is just something that comes
to life on the screen and I'm glad people
have the opportunity to see that themselves.
I was just gonna ask about that because that
is such a big part of the film as well, is
really that love and connection between the
two of them. Um and I wanted to see from your
perspective, what role support that Mark Kelly
gave to Gabby Giffords, What what role did
that play in her recovery? Because you told
me that you often see people have family members
pull away actually from them because the communication
is difficult. Yes, so isolation is a very
big reality for people who have a fazer any
communication difficulty. It's very tempting
to pull back to not go out and communicate
with colleagues, friends, family and also
family members, friends, people who don't
understand of Asia just feel uncomfortable
with a communication struggle will back out
of somebody's life. And so, you know, furthering
that kind of isolation. And Mark really has
just stepped in and sort of turned that idea
on its head. He is so supportive of Gabby
and I think probably the best pieces, his
sense of humor. He the two of them really
have this wonderful dynamic, but he, you know,
if something comes out wrong, that is not
something that is like that. There's nothing
off limits as far as making jokes about things
and they both tease each other. It's just
it's fabulous to watch. She has a really great
sense of humor and in addition to that she
has a wonderful singing voice. And I wanted
to ask a little bit about music and singing
and how significant that's been specifically
for her recovery. And I'm curious if you can
explain a little bit about how music plays
a role in the lives of individuals with Aphasia.
Um and specifically for Gabby, how you incorporated
that into her plan of care. Yeah, so there
are some speech pathology interventions that
rely on music intonation and rhythm and I
know that early in Gabby's rehabilitation
when she was still in Houston. They were doing
some work just from seeing it in the film
um using those approaches, those melodic types
of approaches. And we didn't do a lot of that
early on when we started working together
because she had a lot of the kind of meaningful
or functional communication without needing
to use those types of approaches. I typically
use those for folks who really struggle with
each word. Um but it we found out as we started
working on speeches and longer and longer
speeches that incorporated a lot of more technical
vocabulary, a lot of multi syllable words
that if there were words or phrases that were
difficult for her to say, sometimes we could
incorporate some intonation and some rhythm
to help her master those lines. So we have
sort of come full circle really and started
incorporating rhythm and um kind of melody
and um intonation into uh speech practice.
But I think even more than that music is just
something that has always been a really important
part of Gabby's life and continues to be part
of it. So we'll have times during a therapy
session where we will just burst into song
or if we need a break from a really intensive
session, will just sing and I try to not sing
so loud because her voice is fabulous, but
it's such a, you know, if it's a release for
her, but there's such joy in her face and
in her voice when she sings. I think it's
really good for her soul, even beyond what
it might be doing for speech and language
skills, it just lights up her face and yeah,
it's such a key part of just her life, not
just her rehabilitation, it sounds like it's
very freeing for her in much the same way
that I imagine jumping out of a plane is which
we witnessed. Um and you told me she is a
daredevil and really loves loves life and
that feeling of the wind in her hair and and
and being free. Um so I imagine it's a little
bit similar to that feeling of freedom. Um
I want to ask you from your perspective, what
do you believe people should take away from
seeing this film and and more personally,
how has Gabby inspired you? I hope that people
will take away from the film, that feeling
that they can overcome anything. You know,
seeing somebody who experience such a tragedy
in her life to go from that to being this
vibrant, determined, wonderful person and
always looking forward and not looking back,
I hope that's what folks lead with that. They
shouldn't be looking back at the things that
have weighed them down. But really looking
forward to what they can do and how they can
make a difference in people's lives. That's
what I hope they get away from it. And as
far as how Gabby inspires me, where to start
just yesterday, she called me and I had one
thing I was talking about work and she said
move ahead, don't look back and like, oh yeah,
I mean it can apply across every setting,
whether it's a real tragedy that you don't,
you shouldn't look back and you should move
forward. Just your everyday life when something
gets you down sometimes takes me a moment
to remember that I have that power to just
put that aside and move forward and do my
best at whatever I'm doing so well said and
she's truly uh an inspiration to so many and
and as I believe, resilience personified.
Um she is a bundle of resilience. Um Thank
you so much for this conversation uh and for
all of your work with all of your patients,
the amazing work that you do, that's all the
time we have for now. Um And thank you all
for joining us. Just a programming note. CNN
films will premiere. Gabby. Giffords won't
back down for television on sunday november
20th 2022 at nine p.m. Eastern and pacific
on CNN we hope you tune in. Thanks again so
much